okay so the topic of this video are
gonna be some of the basic features of
all life on earth so let's get started
well first of all let's talk about you
know just what is biology you know
you're often gonna hear biology is the
study of life but it's a little more
complicated than that well first of all
you know polar bears our polar bear is a
living organism studied within the realm
of biology and of course the answer is
yes but what about flowers are flowers
and plants a living organism that falls
within the realm of biology yes
and then bacteria are bacteria living do
they fall within the realm of biology
yes of course but then it starts to get
a little tricky
the Sun is the Sun alive and hopefully
you know the answer is no the Sun is not
alive and yet it falls within the realm
of biology because it has a big impact
on life no water is water alive no not
at all
but water is very much studied within
the realm of biology because water has a
big impact on life no DNA
you know is is the molecule DNA
alive-again molecules no no molecules
are alive but molecules like DNA are
absolutely within the realm of biology
because DNA happens to be a Malecha that
is really the foundation of life
Mountains our mountains of living of
course that mountains are often just you
know big rocks pushed up through
geologic processes our mountains of
living no not at all but they fall
within the realm of biology because
again life inhabits these mountains and
depends upon them so the study of life
is you know a little vague but we hope
to expand on that as as we go through
this well moving forward here life on
Earth you know exists within a small
range of our planet known as the
biosphere and when I look at this
picture right here you know I don't see
anything labeled biosphere in the
pictures so where is the biosphere well
if we zoom on in a little bit to the
crust what we're gonna see this picture
shows nine
what the biosphere is the biosphere
ranges from the highest point above sea
level
you know Mount Everest to the deepest
ocean trench the the Mariana Trench and
and within that range is where life can
be found and this is what is called the
biosphere so the biosphere is the layer
where we find life the layer of the
earth and actually you could probably
say the layer would the crust in the and
the lower atmosphere where life exists
okay and what we can say about life on
Earth is that it's incredibly diverse
you know there's own over two million
known species you know when I look at
this picture right here I see that there
are six big categories or kingdoms of
life you know
flowers are obviously a type of plant a
dog it is a type of an animal you know
mushrooms are a type of fungus then
there's the other three kingdoms that
might be a little less familiar to us
you know amoebas and creatures that swim
around in pond water our members of
kingdom Protista and then there's two
kingdoms of bacteria there are the u
bacteria and there are the archaea or
the archaea bacteria but there's an
incredible diversity of life on Earth
and the pattern that we typically see is
along the equator of the earth is where
generally speaking life tends to be more
diverse you know these areas are a
little warmer have more liquid water
rained upon them and so this is where we
see the most diversity you know within
tropical rainforests well within biology
we often study species organisms that
can create fertile offspring
you know the reason a man and a woman
can typically create a child is because
their DNA is almost identical to one
another about 99.9% identical and so for
that reason we are able to reproduce and
create fertile offspring but what about
a horse in a human if they were to try
to breed would a son tire Bieber
hopefully hopefully you know the answer
is no what we're different species and
the reason we're not able to reproduce
with one another is because the DNA of a
human and the DNA of a horse are just
two different it's not compatible well
what about a chimpanzee you might know
that chimpanzees have a lot of DNA in
common with humans over 98% can we
reproduce with each other no even though
our DNA is over 98% identical it's just
not not similar enough and so members of
the same species their DNA is compatible
to the point where they can reproduce in
human and chimp just aren't well one
thing about life on Earth is that it's
old it's estimated that life on Earth
goes back about 3.5 billion years ago in
the form of bacteria and so these rock
formations called stromatolites these
are caused by mineral buildup from
cyanobacteria type of bacteria and these
are some of the oldest evidence of life
on Earth so we've identified science has
identified that life on Earth goes back
a pretty long time 3.5 billion years old
and so let's talk about some
characteristics you know all life has a
few common characteristics well if we
were in class we'd talk to our neighbors
and and share some of our answers but
we're just gonna go ahead and move
forward
you
so one thing all life is made from cells
or at least one cell and so the cell is
what we call the most basic unit of life
that is capable of carrying on life
processes you know when I look at this
picture I can see that a cell has many
internal parts why don't we call the
nucleus the most basic unit of life why
don't we call a mitochondria the most
basic unit of life why don't we call the
Golgi body the most basic you know like
why is it the overall cell the most
basic well that's because the cell is
the most basic that can still carry on
life the individual internal parts just
can't function on their own without the
overall cell and so what we've learned
over the years that is that cells have
become specialized to perform various
duties you know these two pictures right
here are fairly common to what you would
find in a textbook plant cell that's
square or rectangular an animal cell
that's kind of around a shape you know
these are very vague in general
descriptions of of cells in reality
cells are very specialized and often
have a shape it allows that aids in
their function now for instance here's
red blood cells these actually are
roundish because they can roll without
getting clogged in narrow veins and
arteries as these cells are delivering
oxygen throughout the body but not all
cells around you know you might know
that neurons or nerve cells almost look
like trees with branches and roots on
them to better send electrical signals
to and from the brain sperm cells have a
long whip-like tail in order to swim and
through the female reproductive system
in order to transfer DNA in chromosomes
to the next generation
another characteristic that all life has
is the requirement and the need of
energy energy is the ability to do work
and cause change well here's a young
lady who is about to eat a meal and as
she eats this hamburger goes into her
stomach words eventually digested and
from the stomach the food exits the
stomach and moves into the small
intestines and from the small intestines
the food is broken down into G for
glucose and that glucose often gets
transported to the liver and the liver
will often release that glucose all
throughout our body as we go through our
day and this allows us to you know do
our day-to-day activities and so there's
really two categories of energy users
within biology there are the autotrophs
now if you break the word Auto and troph
prefix and suffix Auto means self and
troph means feeding so these are
organisms that can feed themselves they
feed themselves by doing photosynthesis
and so autotrophs perform photosynthesis
they create sugars they create energy in
the form of sugars from using sunlight
and so with some sunlight shining and
with some rain falling this plant will
also take in some carbon dioxide from
the air and through the process of
photosynthesis well give off oxygen into
the sky but more importantly for the
plant
it creates c6h12o6 that's the formula
for glucose simple sugars such as
glucose and this is why plants do
photosynthesis good because they're
hungry and they're trying to make the
glucose and so when we think of
photosynthetic organisms you know we
often think of plant but they're not the
only photosynthetic organisms on earth
there's also algae which is a type of
Protista member of kingdom Protista and
there's also the cyanobacteria and so
there's many organisms besides plans
are photosynthetic so the second type of
organisms or category of organisms that
that use energy are the heterotrophs now
we already know that troph means feeding
but hetero hetero means different these
are organisms that feed themselves in a
different a different way and so
probably the most obvious of the
heterotrophs are the consumers you know
those consumers that only eat meat
we call them carnivores those consumers
that eat plants we call them herbivores
and those consumers that will eat plants
and meat we call omnivores and so
heterotroph I should say consumers
consumers are one type of heterotroph
and then there are the heterotrophs that
obtain their nutrients by feeding upon
dead material and these are the
decomposers within the decomposer
category there's a there's two different
types of decomposers a mushroom would
represent the sacrifice they absorb
nutrients from dead organisms they
release enzymes to digest their whatever
they're growing upon and then they
absorb the nutrients into their cells
and then a vulture might represent a
good example of a de treatable it
actually ingests nutrients from dead
organisms maybe this vulture didn't kill
the skunk in the picture maybe it
stumbled upon the dead the dead skunk
but it will still ingest its flesh and
muscle and and obtain nutrients that way
okay so moving on we're gonna come to
our third characteristic life responds
to the environment and because life
responds to to a stimulus a factor that
will produce some sort of reaction you
know heat touch heat cold these are
things that are called a stimulus that
causes to Rhea to respond in some way
here we have a young woman with a and
someone sneaks up behind her and puts an
ice cube on her shoulder you know almost
instantly she's gonna jump away and
respond perhaps verbally that
maybe she you know she felt the coldness
of that ice cube you know how many times
are we watching a scary movie and all of
a sudden boo you know a monster appears
on screen and the loud startling music &
noise appears and that causes a stimulus
of response from us and so we've
responded to the environment to the
stimulus that we were provided well as
our body responds to the environment our
body tries to maintain a nice balance
internally and this is called
homeostasis the process where the body
maintains a constant internal
environment you know temperature of 98.6
degrees that's probably the most obvious
thing that our body works really hard to
maintain but our body also works to
maintain the pH of our blood around 7.35
so a very very weak base on the pH scale
and our body was really hard to maintain
a small amount of blood sugar and if any
of these values stray too high or too
low below normal there could be some
serious negative health effects and so
what our body does to maintain
homeostasis is negative feedback most of
the time what our body does to maintain
homeostasis is negative feedback the
process where your body is going to
reverse a change that's happening now
before I go into some biology examples
let's look at a example of negative
feedback in your house you know here's a
layout of a small home you know
somewhere in the middle of your house
you probably have a thermostat mounted
on the wall and this helps to control
the temperature inside your house and
let's not forget you have the heating
and air-conditioning vents and ducts all
behind the walls and your thermostat is
connected to your furnace by a wire well
let's say that you have set the
thermostat to be 72 degrees but right
now it's really cold inside your house
it's 68 degrees so what happens your
thermostat will send a signal to your
furnace your furnace will respond by
producing heat and
blowing heat into the in the throughout
your home and little by little the heat
will go to 69 70 71 and eventually back
to the setpoint and when that happens
your thermostat sends a signal to the
furnace and the whole thing turns off
negative feedback reversed the coldness
and brought your the temperature of your
home back to normal that's what negative
feedback does let's look at some biology
examples now so here we have a young
child caught outside on a cold winter
night now right now his core temperature
is 98.6 degrees but the longer he's
exposed to cold you can see his core
temperature is dropping he's getting
colder and colder and colder and you
know what happens when you start to get
too cold you start to shiver that
uncontrollable shaking of your muscles
rubbing on other muscles produces
friction and friction produces heat and
it's this heat that slowly begins to
warm us closer to normal and eventually
we get back to normal and the shivering
stops but again a great example of
negative feedback because your body
worked to reverse the change the change
was that this child was getting too cold
and your body worked to reverse that
well the opposite is true as well here
we have a young lady at the beach in
core temperature 98.6 degrees but the
longer you're exposed to the heat of the
day her body temperature increases and
then gets hotter and gets hotter and
gets hot and you know what happens if
you get too warm you start to sweat you
start to produce droplets of sweat
throughout you all over your body well
how does this actually cool you off as
the sweat evaporates heat is pulled away
from your body and eventually your
temperature goes down so the more you
sweat the more sweat the will evaporate
and pull heat away from your body and
the more you sweat this one evaporates
and it pulls heat away from your body
and eventually you're back to normal
again
negative feedback reverses the change
that was happening to you
well what about positive feedback
positive feedback is a little more rare
positive feedback will actually
encourage or promote a change that's
happening to your body well before we go
through a biological example let's look
at again an example of positive feedback
in your home well throughout your home
you have smoke alarms scattered in most
rooms of your home let's say in the
middle of the night a fire breaks out in
the corner of the room and you're
sleeping so you don't even know it's
happening
well one of the smoke alarms will begin
to let off that loud piercing noise now
look at the definition of positive
feedback whatever change is happening is
going to be promoted and encouraged
so as this smoke alarm goes off it will
send a signal to all the other smoke
alarms and the alert is promoted the
alert is encouraged and so this you this
way you can see in this example you know
you can be woken up and you can get to
safety but positive feedback well
encourage change and promote it now
let's go through some biological
examples so a great example of positive
feedback are the muscle contractions
that begin in a woman's uterus when
she's about to give birth to a newborn
child these muscle contractions begin
very slow at first and then what happens
a signal gets sent to the woman's brain
the brain will respond by releasing a
hormone now ask yourself if this was
negative feedback what would happen to
the contractions look at the definition
negative feedback would reverse this
change do we want to reverse do we want
to reverse and stop these contractions
if we were to do that the baby would
never be delivered so in this case
positive feedback will encourage the
change positive feedback will promote
the the muscle contractions and so the
hormones released actually cause the
muscle contractions that speed up so the
baby will be delivered in birth in a
more timely manner
okay moving on we come to another
characteristic that all life shares and
that's the ability to reproduce and
develop well reproduction reproduction
is simply passing on DNA genetic
material from one generation to the next
we can break reproduction down to its
its most simplest form and that's
passing DNA to the next generation
well when we look at how life reproduces
well those that reproduce sexually you
know inside of the sperm cell there is
DNA from the the male and inside of this
egg cell there is DNA from the female
and so sexual reproduction has figured
out a way to combine DNA from the male
with the female but not every type of
organism reproduces sexually some
organism let's talk about the two types
of reproduction some organisms reproduce
asexually without another individual
here we have an animation of a cell
slowly dividing itself into two cells
and so when organisms reproduce
asexually they are genetically identical
to one another the offspring that are
created are genetically identical to the
parent and so we basically have cloning
by Nature here examples of organisms
that reproduce this way bacteria
Protista and even some fungus and some
plants and some animals however most
fungus plants and animals reproduce
reproduce sexually but let's look at a
quick example in animals here's an
animal by the name of a Hydra and it's
experiencing budding in the picture you
can see a new individual is growing off
of the body of the parent and eventually
it will pop off and float away in the
ocean and a sexually reproducing and
then there's sexual reproducing every
production and as we said earlier this
is where sperm cell from a male egg cell
from a female and so in that sperm cell
there's DNA
from the father and in this egg cell
there is DNA from the mother
and so organisms that reproduce sexually
produce offspring that is a genetic
mixture of two parents and so most
fungus reproduced this way most plants
reproduce this way in most animals like
the the two insects that you see in the
picture reproduce sexually well you
might be asking well how does a plant
for example how does a plant reproduce
sexually
well here's to two flowers you know side
by side in a forest pretend and on the
flower to the left the red dots
represent pollen which is the equivalent
of male sperm and on the right that
black dot you see there is the egg cell
the female part of the plow of the
flower well a bumble bee for example
might buzz around feeding on nectar and
when it does it gets pollen all over
itself and when it flies away you can
see the pollen is stuck to it and
eventually this bee might buzz around
the neighboring plant and by doing this
accidentally transfers pollen that's the
Act called pollination now the the sperm
cell has to still grow all the way down
to where the egg is and that eventually
does happen but here we have the process
where some plants will reproduce
sexually
okay so we've gone over some
characteristics of life well now I want
to ask you something
is fire alive you know for in class we
talked about this with our neighbor but
right now we're gonna just move up it's
fire made of cells no not at all does
fire require energy to burn yes of
course this fire will respond
differently to one environment versus
another yes fire behaves differently in
various environments can a fire
reproduce I would argue yes asexually
you know if a fire is burning and a
spark were to jump and land somewhere
else it might spark a second fire can
fire grow and develop I would say yes
you know a forest fire doesn't begin
out of control forest fires might begin
you know when somebody throws a
cigarette out of their car and it slowly
grows and develops into a a pretty big
fire so is fire alive I hope you know
the answer to this question is no of
course not fire is not a living organism
but it does possess some of the
qualities of life well let's look at
something else something that should be
a little more obvious is a car alive
well is a car made of cells parts of it
you could argue yes you know leather
interior and the cloth interior of a car
maybe the wood paneling some cars have
wood on them so you could say that parts
of cars are made from cells does a car
require energy yes of course well a car
responded to its environment what
depends upon the car some cars with
advanced technology will respond to you
know dry and Sun and wetness of the road
can a car reproduce no not at all can a
car grow and develop
well no humans have developed cars and
built them and assembled them so our car
is alive you can see that cars do have
some qualities of life our cars living
of course not
no not at all but I hope you see the
point I'm making with the fire example
in the car example there's a lot of
objects that will possess some of these
qualities of life but in order to be
considered living we think we have a
pretty good checklist here what it means
to be alive so as we wrap up this video
you know if you're in my bio class you
know try to answer these questions and a
separate sheet of paper and I'm happy to
check your answers before school or
after school one day hope you found this
video helpful thanks for watching